tonight this is your captain speaking
it's et's top gun takeover
as maverick lands in theaters i'm trying
to deliver for you okay behind the
scenes secrets from the movie over 30
years in the making just a little bush
how tom's maverick mission he said so
jen
you ever been in the pb2 before pushes
co-stars to the limit you're strapped to
a chair you're blindfolded plus our
flashback to the set of the original who
didn't grow up wanting to fly an f-14
et's top gun special
takes off right now
we'll just have to see
top gun mavericks flight plan reignite
the summer box office oh my gosh what a
spectacular day welcome to entertainment
tonight aboard the uss midway in san
diego california yeah we're outside
today kevin frazier so much of the
original movie was filmed around this
city and 36 years later this spot was
tom cruise's top pick for the sequel's
global premiere and e.t was his first
stop
[Music]
so apparently mr cruz is going to have
an epic arrival tonight
i wouldn't expect anything less there's
only one way to come into a top gun
movie you got to fly in there's only one
of those guys and here he comes the best
of that arrival that you had come on tom
that's fun
from his action star entrance to this
military flyover look at that
tom's global premiere on the uss midway
was a full throttle spectacle
celebrating the release of top gun
beverage this is quite a moment it's
been 36 years for this film the fans
have been asking for it all around the
world
okay question is where are you piloting
the helicopter not today i do fly that
helicopter but not today i didn't fly it
you know there were so many beautiful
moments in the film that i loved um but
i think the most beautiful were the
scenes with you and val you know the
first one i really rallied hard for him
to make the movie you're everyone's
problem and the kind of talent that he
has
and you see that scene is very special
this is very special
for the long-awaited sequel tom picks up
the story as maverick in the mojave
desert back again as a test pilot and
bucking authority
maverick of course is is a guy that
pushes the limits he always goes like
you say go to the line he goes right
over the line i'm saying just a little
bit if i'm being honest i see a little
bit of that in tom cruise
little bush
it's no
easy feat making a sequel to you know
top gun 30 some years later but we
really did everybody worked so hard so
to to have that kind of
you know rewarded and feel that right
now is really special it's daunting and
there's not one person in this movie
that wasn't sweating bullets and i said
you know what
if you're not sweating bullets making
this film you shouldn't be on this movie
tom kept the maverick momentum going two
weeks later he received a hero's welcome
at the cannes film festival tom waved to
fans and helped his on-screen love
jennifer connelly up those famous 24
steps on the red carpet the whole cast
watched in awe of another flyover this
time it was a squadron of french fighter
jets
[Applause]
after the premiere tom and the film
received a five-minute standing ovation
then it was off to london
all right here we go
maverick the ultimate aviator you sir
are the ultimate actor
where did this passion of yours first
begin for what you do you know when i
was a little kid i want to make movies i
remember being four years old literally
and the moment that i wanted to make
films i wanted to fly i just wanted to
travel the world and meet people
the king of action held court with
prince william and duchess kate and
again ever the gentleman this time tom
helped the duchess of cambridge up the
stairs
i hear william is a top gun fanatic is
this true that you've already given him
an advanced screening of the film so
this will be a second time singing yes
early on he was an aviator so i know
we'd have a lot of fun have the two of
you ever flown together not yet
get ready pilots are pilots so we all
want to we all want to go flying
it really pushes the envelope and that's
what i think people come to a movie like
this to see so i'm here with the actors
and
when we're making the film we're talking
about moments like this
to have a premiere and i wanted them to
have this kind of experience and then to
have a royal premiere in england it's
very special it's very very special i
think this is really a once in a
lifetime experience if you told me that
this is not real wake up danny wake up
i'd be like yeah i should wake up and
then i'll wait like i'll be back as a
16 year old in miami just about to go to
soccer practice
[Music]
tom's whirlwind tour didn't end there
four days later he was in japan with
super producer jerry bruckheimer for a
fireworks show and making hand hearts
for fans
[Music]
and while he was overseas we were in the
big apple with tom's co-star mr payback
jay ellis for a times square takeover
handing out tickets for an advanced
screening of maverick we got cop gun
tickets payback
i'm one of the pilots in the movie yeah
oh that's a boy yeah
future pilot i see it it's a future
pilot i got to be there at the london
premiere with y'all we met the royals
no one knew what to say
it was crazy what do you ask him i asked
uh prince william what type of aircraft
he flew miles teller at one point goes
your eyes are so blue he's like they're
like an ocean
no one knew what to say oh wow
so after getting to observe
the legend that is tom cruise what was
the insight you gained from him super
kind super gracious like told stories
hours after we wrapped and he would
still be sitting there telling us
stories
and people just throwing them questions
it was it was amazing tom did more than
tell stories on the set we found out
what being a top gun is all about from
the rest of the cast when we sat down
with them on the uss midway
you remember when you saw the original
top gun at st louis missouri i was 15
years old i just remember coming out of
the movie and immediately wanting to go
see it again you know i can't i still
can't believe that i'm you know 30 some
odd years later i'm in the sequel to the
thing of course this sequel is full of
high-flying action and as for that
reunion between tom and val well the
guys told us having iceman on the set
melted everyone's heart
there's one particular scene between val
and tom that just
man
right in the fields talking to tom about
that moment
it really was like they started their
careers out together they've had this
wild amazing journey and you know top
gun holds such a
beautiful place for both of them val's
voice is pretty compromised at this
point um
and uh but you could tell his energy was
was still the same and he was very
playful and excited and you could tell
the feeling of of that nostalgic reunion
energy was all very much there and he he
was participating in that a lot it was
great to see him so the beach football
montage is it true that you guys shot it
twice because tom was like i didn't like
the way that was the first time we don't
know why we shot it a second time
there's nothing that really is a buzz
kill to a tater tot bite
your shirt
exactly
when you're flying you also had to
direct the cameras inside the jets
you're responsible for making sure all
the cameras roll you're responsible for
your makeup and your hair and your your
all your props you're communicating to
your pilot while you're also acting
at the same time i would get off these
flights and i would drive my car to in
and out get a double double and then i'd
fall asleep in the cab of my truck wake
up and it's like five hours later it's
night time i'm like what just happened
to my body the guys also had to learn
how to survive a water crash training in
the dunker just like the military you're
strapped to a chair you're blindfolded
and then they slowly start submerging
you in water
you take you take a final breath and
then it starts to flip you upside down
and then you have to get out i said this
is active abuse but then you see tom do
the same course that you just did and
it's like oh there's there's levels to
passing this test and it wasn't just the
guys who endured the dunker so did one
of the female fighter pilots on the team
monica barbaro
oh yeah there was one moment in my head
i went i can't do this i can't do this i
can't do like the panic started to rise
and this weird voice came from within
and was like you have to it was like one
of those just
fear overcoming moments that that lives
with you forever good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking before
shooting jennifer had a crippling fear
of flying tom helped her out with that
you know originally i wasn't supposed to
fly in the movie because my character is
not an aviator i was actually in the
plane with him
shooting a scene that was just supposed
to be on the tarmac and uh
he said so jen have you ever been in a
pediatric one before and i said no i
haven't it just hasn't come up for me
and he said have you ever done any uh
aerobatic flying before at all and i
said no why is this going somewhere he's
like well it's just gonna be very gentle
we're gonna do some general rules and
yeah you know he's an incredible pilot
and it was pretty magical
very impressive
[Music]
and then that moment on the back of the
bike i mean that is an iconic moment for
the franchise it was really fun and
again you know just not something that
comes up in my everyday life riding on a
motorcycle with tom cruise i can't hear
you
[Music]
now would you believe tom actually
learned how to ride a motorcycle on the
original top gun and of course e.t was
on the set
who didn't grow up wanting to fly an
f-14 it's very easy falling into the
role i am dangerous
i feel it's some of my best work tom
called it top gun would become the
highest grossing film of 1986 earning
over 350 million and 36 years later its
quotes still live on i feel the need
the need for
me to bed or speed
me forever show me the way home buddy
[Music]
that was a line uh we got uh
from one of the pilots i mean there's no
time to think up there if you have to
think you're dead if you think
you're dead top gun had it all karaoke
fast motorcycles and an unforgettable
slo-mo beach volleyball scene
but some things you might not know about
the film
this love scene was actually added after
production wrapped it had to be shot in
silhouette because kelly mcgillis had
dyed her hair brown for her next roll
same goes for why she wore a hat in the
elevator the female lead in
an all-male cast it's great
i feel like camp counselor
while the role of maverick was written
for tom he originally turned it down
multiple times other stars reportedly
considered for the role rob lowe charlie
sheen and robert downey jr don't you see
yourself as being the the sex symbol
that the audience does not really no of
course aside from anthony edwards and
meg ryan who dated in real life after
the film wrapped val kilmer and tim
robbins i'm bringing a bit closer merlin
the film's other stars were the f-14s it
won't be all blue screen with
fake jets flying around us we'll really
be up there
real top gun pilots on set made sure
everything was authentic do these
hollywood types really have the right
stuff to be top gun
they're trainable barely you'll just
have to see a-listers attended the
film's new york premiere including cher
who dated both tom and val in the mid
80s it's very exciting it's very
american i think it'll be a very
beautiful movie and it's very inspiring
all the actors
we all had a great time
[Music]
you